[Music]
lewis lewis is in florida hi lewis how
are you
hey good day how you guys doing better
than i deserve what's up
hey uh it's an honor speaking to you um
really quick
i want to say uh i thank the lord
because of you
and uh me and my wife pay up uh eleven
thousand dollars
uh last week good for you and uh yeah
and uh
the question that i have is about my
family i came from cuba like probably
like 10 years ago
i met my wife uh
and now i'm kind of like i'm the weird
guy in the family
because the reason that i want to pay
cash for everything
and i don't really know how to how to
like
you know you know like how let me say
real quick i i
i have a little girl she's three years
old and we have two two cars
they all pay off thank god and uh what's
the problem with your family
you know that they go after me saying oh
why don't buy a new car you know
you you have you have a nice credit why
you don't do this they try
to to take me again to take me back to
to the you know to death
how old are you i'm 28. i'm 28. so
you're like a full-grown man
yeah i know but
yeah dave i i understand and i i i'm a
fighter private i'm i'm always listening
to you and
i love you but but but the thing is
it really affects sometimes when like
when you're under the party and all
these
crazy people you know trying to to you
know and you know that they completely
wrong because
the plan is so clear and it's so easy
like to do it here's the deal you know
what i'm saying like oh yeah totally
totally louis yeah i'm gonna free
you today you ready yeah just put it
down
and i wish it was more complex than that
they don't get a vote you're in charge
of
um you and your wife are in charge of
your money
and you and your wife are in charge of
how you raise your daughter
and i i love my parents
i love my in-laws i love my brother and
sister
and they don't get to vote and they give
me advice
they give me their opinions they give me
their like you know what i think
and i hear them and i smile and i laugh
and if i feel
like they've crossed some kind of value
line with me which is rare i'll push
back
but they don't get a vote and i sleep
soundly
keeps you from spending a lot of time
arguing yeah i see people that you're
not gonna change their mind and they're
not gonna change your mind
i've got relatives that don't know how
to vote they vote the wrong way
and i love them anyway that's right
they're still my i still love them
but there's no sense discussing this
stuff with them no i don't have these
discussions
because they're going to continue to
vote the wrong way and i can't do
anything about it and when it comes with
comes with debt what i've found over
time is people watch how you live
and they watch the light way you walk
through challenging situations
and louis i i can almost guarantee you
in two years and five years and seven
years
people are gonna start pulling you aside
at a party and saying hey man tell me
about this uh
and they'll pull you aside they won't do
it tell me about this dave ramsey they
ridicule you in front of everybody but
they'll pull you aside when they want to
know how you won
freedom is a light and it shines don't
get a vote put it down
put it down baby dr john's right